[Music]
what's going on guys The Walking Dead
it's coming back this weekend what's
better than talking about The Walking
Dead talking about it with one of its
cast members that's right we are super
lucky to have a gentleman a scholar a
Renaissance man he plays Aaron on the
walking dead you can see him in the
upcoming sheep and wolves animated
feature and he's the voice of han Solo
in the Star Wars based trials on
Tatooine Ross Marquand dude welcome to
the show yeah okay just first question
right off the bat who Denis can kill he
kills and that's what happened so play
that back very slowly maybe you'll hear
something you probably want to ruin it
okay tell me about the the levels of
secrecy is this like CIA levels that's
happening to keep the secrets of The
Walking Dead they're very secretive yeah
and basically saying hey if you want to
keep working for The Walking Dead keep
that mouth shut like zip it throw away
the key stamp on the key oh and like
bury the key because that's how it is I
shouldn't even be talking right now do
you ever come in contact with fan
theories Walking Dead I really do yeah
because the Internet's full of them do
people ask you when you meet them at
conventions they do you do it they ask
me even my parents ask me they try to
like try to test my my willingness to
break and just open up about it I don't
though I never break so Ross I'm going
to throw some fan theories for you and
these fan theories we scoured the
deepest reaches of the Internet and went
on Reddit and found several Walking Dead
fan theories that I'm just going to get
this man's learn it opinion on some are
saying Rick is a zombie really one
theory speculates that Rick isn't Walker
bait he's an actual Walker who's immune
to the virus and just reanimates as
himself like some kind of
post-apocalyptic Groundhog Day others go
even further to say that Karl is also a
Walker and he has died this is [ __ ]
that's that's that's kind of [ __ ]
yeah yeah all right boom we just
disproved a major
what major Walking Dead fan theory let
me ask you this question the Walker
virus ah brought to Earth by aliens how
could an alien civilization conquer an
entire planet without destroying its
natural resources by unleashing a killer
virus that destroys all life but leaves
the planet intact
the lack of a concrete cause for the
virus has led many to speculate that an
extraterrestrial may have phoned in a
virus to murder humanity Robert Kirkman
even used this as a premise to pitch the
idea in the first place he now says this
was all just bait and switch or was it
that Kirkman I'll tell you he is a he is
a gosh that brain of his he just he
tells you one thing and then whoa you
know that he does my man that he does
loves doing that so aliens ya know it's
it is I thought yeah it is yeah it's an
I don't know whether to believe you or
not it's an alien virus everyone knows
that does everyone know that it's like
Geico are you serious not the alien
thing though am I not I don't know I
can't tell if you're [ __ ] with me dude
you got a poker face I don't I don't
mess around when it comes to alien
viruses you heard it here from Ross
Marquand that it came from aliens aliens
thank you for firming with each of the
cameras there's another theory called
the AMC shared universe theory Breaking
Bad and The Walking Dead exist in the
same universe
that makes a lot of sense because
there's an RV yes that's where the
similarities end for me but but keep
going there have been several subtle and
not-so-subtle nods to other to another
AMC show on The Walking Dead Breaking
Bad but to these shows share a universe
consider these examples Glenn driving a
car that exactly matches the one Walter
White bought for his son Walter jr.
Murrells drug stash from season two see
anything familiar was their method blue
meth come on blue meth I don't remember
that I don't know how that blue meth
traveled from New Mexico to Atlanta but
there was blue meth Darrell yeah
described Murrells drug dealer and a
clip from season four
the guy used the word [ __ ] he pulls a
gun that's it right here I cuz I'm gonna
kill you [ __ ] irrefutable evidence
crossovers yo so do you think AMC shared
universe is that a credible theory yes
Wow Ross let's get your feelings on the
Toy Story Theory the Toy Story theory
posits that the story of The Walking
Dead is parallel to the Pixar film
series Toy Story and this goes way
deeper than I have time to go but
there's a just a few highlights the
heroes of both stories are law
enforcement officers who wear a badge
and a cowboy hat I'm talking woody I'm
talking Rick they both have story lines
about the sheriff's best friend
competing for the affections of his
small child
both of them have story lines set in
isolated communities featuring a
friendly southern villain who hides his
evil behind southern charm and both of
them feature a young child murdering his
own mother by shooting her in the head
right that last person only walk yeah I
don't remember that okay okay
Rick woody Shane buzz Karl Andy
lots of hug and bear the governor so all
that stuff I listed on a scale of one to
ten how much validity with ten being
like that spot-on one being like what
are you crazy I'm gonna have to go with
the three point seven okay yeah cuz
there is some validity to that but not
enough for me to really you know sink my
teeth into it finally Ross there are
theories saying that negan killed
everyone not literally not like he went
down the line with his bat Bam Bam Bam
Bam killer know that like the individual
it could have been anyone so I'm just
going to read you a couple of these I
know you're sworn to secrecy but feel
free to comment as much or as little as
you care to one detailed analysis of
negan's eenie meenie miney mo game
determine that Glenn got the bat
anything to say about eenie meenie miney
moe
any comments do you ever use eenie
meenie miney mo as a child I've never
heard of it another one determined it
was fan favorite Darryl who they say
what like was Death Proof but I love
Death Proof was great movie another one
said that since you see no hair in the
first person camera view at the end of
the episode
Michonne Rick Carol Darryl and Glenn
safe one more is a good one it's called
Orange Crush theory which says that
season six is spotlight on the Orange
Crush tipped off the fact that ginger ah
one of the greatest moustaches on
television Abraham got the bat
product placement or subtle
foreshadowing I think it was actually a
subtle tip of the hat if you will to the
nineteen eighty uh defense of the Denver
Broncos the Orange Crush and not for
nothing but there are detailed analyses
that claim it's you Ross
that there's actually a dead man sitting
right here on the set of screen junkies
thoughts are we all dead in the Sylvia
Plath sense of the word me but Ross in
all seriousness you won't tell us that
will you I can't let me ask them a
question who do you think died are you
excited for the season 7 premiere of The
Walking Dead I know I am let us know in
the comments section below we want to
know what you're thinking you know I was
looking forward to this and Ross
Marquand you do not disappoint thank you
oh of course please watch the season
premiere of The Walking Dead Sunday
October 23rd 9:00 8:00 central
oh you dot you gotta watch it to find
out if you love The Walking Dead and
you'll want to see more awesome Walking
Dead stuff you've got to check out our
hilarious screen junkies Roast of Rick
Grimes that's right we roast the lawman
himself I play negan I do a pretty
freakin good job taking everybody to pee
pants city it's a blast
so click on the link right here or the
one in the description below and then
you can register and watch the Roast of
Rick Grimes for free
thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye please welcome our roast master
[Applause]
Wow I want to thank you all for coming
out tonight